hi I'm ala Woodward I write an online
food blog called deliciously Allah which
is somehow followed by millions of
people I started eating this way just
over two years ago now as a way of
healing a rare condition i was diagnosed
with back in 2011 which is called
postural tachycardia syndrome and a
breakdown or something nervous system
when I suppose that erase my blog rich
with the main 2013 and ever really
intended anybody else to read it and
start with it grew really slowly I think
the first six month had a hundred
thousand hit and then the second six
months and nine hundred thousand and
that's when I started thinking okay
people are reading this and started
taking a bit more seriously and working
more on it you know it's much more
consistent about when I posted i started
doing things like instagram and in the
last 18 months since that happened it's
gone crazy you've had nearly 30 million
hits this month alone
definitely feels a little bit more like
a full-time job in Sunday's instead of
24 hours seven days a week the first
thing I ever did in cooking classes
because that was just because people
said they wanted them I was so nervous
and they put my first one out but it's
all about that night and I realized that
they were obviously something there so I
tried to a couple of cooking class
there's a month and then the two girls
that work with me my kind of delicious
the other team they need some classes
too so that we can do more and then are
two things like supper club and then
talk about a lot of people and decided
to do a nap and that was really the
first kind of commercial thing I did and
that was february2014 and it went to
number one overnight in the UK and the
US on iTunes which was pretty cool and I
think now it's had just over 70,000
downloads and then I got my book deal
and so I've got a book coming out 29th
of January in the UK and instead of
march in the US and it's been number one
on amazon for just over a week now and
it's actually not even out for four days
I was excited to swap some just doing
everything online to physically
publishing a book because online is
really transient and then you see it in
the stats and things people just look at
what happened recently and I think it's
nice as well to sometimes step away from
a computer we spent all our lives at
computers what most people do every day
and actually when you come home it's
kind of nice to be cooking from a book
and flicking through but rather than
more technology I kind of want to become
sort of health and wellness hub least
over here in Europe and kind of go to
place for all your questions about
healthy living and healthy eating how
I'm going to do that or what I'm going
to do in between I'm not tell me sure
but yeah I'm just going to keep going
with it